to present the Foreign Language Film
award
we have important distinguished actor
who excels in drama the musical and
comedy all my fields ladies and
gentlemen this direct Harrison
Rex congratulations on your nomination
thank you very much say yeah funny you
know I was born in England too why did
Jack Warner give you the part but I was
wondering about that because you live so
much near the studios Naidu
you know Rex that's the second part you
beat me out of which was a lebombo
Caesar and Cleopatra you notice me in
that I'm very good
the nominations for the best foreign
language film of the year ravens end ad
Europa film from Sweden salla a salah'
film limited production from Israel the
umbrellas of Cherbourg a park
madellaine beta films production from
France women in the dunes at Ishihara
production from Japan yesterday today
and tomorrow
champion Concordia production from Italy
the envelope the winner is Italy for
yesterday today and tomorrow
something for champion Concordia
Josephine Levine
on behalf of Carl ponte vittorio de sica
my cello must be adding and some feel
around thank you very much
you